alors finalement en France il est tas de
problèmes alors qu'à l'étranger vous
êtes dans une pleine période de
reconnaissance
[Rires]
[Musique]
la boîte qui finalement dans votre vie
elle peut compter oui en fonction de
l'époque bien entendu parce que c'est
c'est
tout le temps
j'ai passé pratiquement toute mes vies
pendant 10 ans
au top 50 alors visez comment maintenant
c'est vrai que vous écrivez seulement à
partir de minuit donc vous écrivez
parce que dans la journée il y a
beaucoup de monde chez moi
ça peut la gare Saint-Lazare alors
j'écris la nuit de minuit à 13h30
ou que ça soit pour une question
d'équilibre équilibre physiologique qui
s'appelle l'équilibre arcadien je crois
le riz parcadien
alors finalement aujourd'hui deux stars
deux femmes écrivains stars en France
durant ces vous vous et Duras vous avez
des carrières qui sont complètement
opposés c'est à dire que vous avez du
succès tout de suite et elle en a eu
plutôt plutôt sur le tard faut bien le
dire
dès le début
était formidable mais si c'était à
refaire vous pensez quoi vous moi je
pense qu'il vaut mieux avoir du sucre
à la hauteur aussi
[Musique]
vous débarrasse l'ambition de la voix
vous avez vu le livre de Christine
avantin qui s'appelle le cœur en poche
et nous on a parlé
de savoir si
l'original l'a lu je ne mangeais pas mal
de nouvelles dans ma vie chaque fois on
lance quoi de nouvelles secondes
et puis
non je sais pas j'ai pas dit je sais pas
j'ai pas eu beaucoup de bien on dit que
ça manque de la fameuse ce qu'on ait pu
entendre d'ailleurs comme mot la petite
musique là mais il parait que ça manque
de ça quand même il paraît qu'elle
raconte un peu ce qu'elle voit à la télé
comme ça mais c'est pas ça fait beaucoup
de progrès c'est la saga après la
seconde après la télé voilà
alors Jean-Paul Sartre vous avez
beaucoup vu dans ces dernières années
j'ai prévu ce dernier
et j'ai pas de chance que j'ai besoin 25
ans j'ai beaucoup admiré j'ai vu un
moment un petit peu pendant ça de loin
et puis on s'est vu de manière un peu
personnel un peu poussé pendant un an et
il va j'ai l'impression d'être d'avoir
découvert et peut-être abandonné aussi
tôt
ça finira par tenir le coup
oui c'est une phrase que dit oui c'est
bien très flatteur dans sa bouche vous
allez entrer l'Académie française alors
non non
parce que mon affaire m'a parlé et on a
demandé de proposer mais j'ai une
manière d'indépendance qui touche à la à
la folie et je trouve ça extrêmement
mais je peux pas
de chance
de voir laisser un peu aller les choses
et de vous avoir reprises là oui au
niveau des livres
pensez que c'était le plus difficile à
faire le plus passionnant mais
avec le Centre d'aquarelle ça prend des
nouvelles dimensions un sujet plus grave
j'ai refusé pendant 25 ans
je finis par être obligé
de plus en plus solides mais vous avez
tout le temps de problème de faits
divers dans votre vie ça vous gêne le
côté paparazzi de la célébrité donc vous
avez été quand même assez victime
en ce moment
nous avons les mêmes je crois
[Musique]
en 81 en 86 et là maintenant on fait un
petit battements
dans la constitution des droits de
l'homme
c'est la liberté
je trouve ça très très dangereux parce
que les gens qui vivent et qui aiment le
lire il y a quelque chose j'en jeûne
imaginer qu'on écrit grâce à
l'apocalypse
c'est finalement
parler
et puis
les gens qui sont moins connus que nous
peuvent se réjouir d'être de l'être mais
pourquoi la police a le droit de violer
le secret d'instruction comme ça à la
police
[Musique]
que votre nom a été divulguée dans cette
affaire moi je pense pas toujours les
fausses ici sérieuses mais le cas
échéant la somme d'embêtement que j'ai
chaque fois avant les élections depuis
que depuis que j'ai fait savoir des
opinions politiques je pense qu'il y a
un rapport quand même alors finalement
en France il y a des tas de problèmes
alors qu'à l'étranger vous êtes dans une
telle période de reconnaissance
[Rires]
[Musique]
parce que les petits enfants
les universités pour faire des
conférences mais ça les conférences
c'est pas tellement bon
[Musique]
l'étranger oui c'est assez flambant la
réputation en France aussi ici les gens
ne sont pas tellement crédules il y a un
livre qui vient de sortir sur vous qui
s'appelle tout simplement Sagan il faut
le lire ou non
je suis pas
oui bien sûr
[Musique]
quand on voit sa propre distance
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu